oh this is random
so imagine if you go to mcdonald's
and you choke on a cooked piece of
someone's covered mask
i'm getting all are you you're suing i'm
getting the bag oh
100 you have to yeah so some uh somebody
choked on a [ __ ]
a chicken nugget because there was a
mask [ __ ] fried into the chicken
nugget first of all
aren't the nuggets already pre-cooked
yeah what is going on with that [ __ ]
like what how does anybody they dipping
them in batter
right they ain't battering the chicken
off the [ __ ] mcdonald's and shits is
coming in a bag frozen on a truck right
shit's been frozen for months dog they
got reserves
by the way can we talk about how amazing
mcdonald's is
no dude being on the keto diet
i probably crave mcdonald's
more than anything else it's whataburger
that's what i miss like [ __ ]
really out here acting like mcdonald's
ain't fire because it ain't dog
mcdonald's is trash
it's the bottom rung bro mcdonald's is
fire bro
there's a reason why they're number one
bud and that's because that [ __ ] is good
it's not good for you but that [ __ ] is
good
this is a trash take dog give me the
number nine
two cheeseburgers i want the basic right
i want that basic entry-level mcdonald's
meal
i'm talking the number nine
it comes with two regular cheeseburgers
a large fry and a coke
that mcdonald's coke is different than
every other coca-cola in the world
it is that's a fact the cold coke tastes
like nothing else
that [ __ ] does just like regular coke
it's that sp it's that fancy coke it's
that goddamn
they got that extra syrup or something
mcdonald's is in no way shape or form
the best fast food dog but
you were tripping i didn't say it was
the best fast food
it's number one though of course yes
that's a fact
number one in the world but right why
though
why would they be number one if it
wasn't good
it's marketing dog people is comfort
food
would it be number one if it if it
didn't taste good
it must have tasted good at some point
you don't think mcdonald's
tastes good i can't remember the last
time i had mcdonald's like damn that was
good like
so you you don't [ __ ] with a goddamn
sausage mcmuffin i was gonna say maybe a
sausage mcmuffin that's about
a hash brown and i usually regret it
hashtag
soggy as [ __ ] every time you eat a
mcdonald's you regret it because you're
you [ __ ]
but i regret it because it tasted like
[ __ ] no i know it sounds good in my head
you're tripping you get that two
cheeseburger meal you get the extra
fries right you get that large fry
and then you just load up them two
little cheeseburgers with fries i think
he fries out you put him on the [ __ ]
and then it's a
and then you get that spicy mcchicken
no lettuce
i bro mcdonald's is john blaze
it is not a dog bro you're [ __ ]
bugging this
this is a horrible take it's not a
horrible take it's true
mcdonald's is fire
yo let me ask you something what's
better carl's jr mcdonald's
that's that's not even a question carl's
jr
that's not true western bacon
cheeseburger [ __ ] over
anything mcdonald's got on the menu i
don't just i don't i do not agree with
you
you want to you're taking this hardest
stance
i love me some carl's jr but it ain't
[ __ ] with mcdonald's bro
dog even the chicken tenders let me ask
you something if you go to mcdonald's
you can kind of just point at the menu
and order something and know it's going
to be solid
you go to carl's jr you can't do that
you can't absolutely
superstar at mcdonald's you just close
your eyes and say you know what
give me the nuggets give me the goddamn
chicken grill i'm gonna give you
diarrhea anyways right so give me that
goddamn fish fillet
with the half a piece of cheese oh dog
bruh mcdonald's is the one
i mean i'll take steak and shake
there's literally almost shake shack any
other
pain i'd rather go to not me
can we what's above mcdonald's for you
then
in and out that's it
i would rather go to whataburger see
whataburgers at the top
but you want to know what the difference
is i don't crave whataburger
i crave that mcdonald's taste those
fries bruh
how about this i'll take mcdonald's
fries over everybody's fries
including in-n-out's fries oh in-n-out
fries are trash
no they're amazing because they're fresh
no
who told you that lie out what do you
mean they [ __ ] cut the potato in the
goddamn drive-through you see the
[ __ ] people cutting the [ __ ]
potato
it's fresh ass dog like it doesn't taste
good
and then shits get cold in like two
seconds listen by the time they hand it
to you
the shit's like ice cubes okay does
mcdonald's have the best fries
all right i might give you that one okay
if our fries not a very important
uh part of every single fast food
restaurant but
[ __ ] taco bell got french fries what
they got them goddamn nacho fries oh no
i don't [ __ ] with these taco bell
creations like you you try all them
shits the fritos
the cheetos
hey don't open up the taco bell can of
worms because we could go there too
can we know you're well versed on that
[ __ ] we have to stop acting like taco
bell ain't fire
taco bell is fire but god damn they
raise those prices every single time
someone talks about taco bell it's in a
negative context
i just don't like all the real
frankenstein creations
not real mexican food yeah no [ __ ]
[ __ ] it's taco bell
it is taco bell it's it's food for
people who
are fat smoke marijuana
and then want food at one in the morning
or people who don't care about
themselves a lot
and i happen to at some point in time or
another
be all three right
i don't care about what i put into my
body i mean i'm not putting heroin in
i'm not putting heroin into my body for
the record but when it comes to food i'm
willing to put all kinds of garbage in
my mouth
pause i've seen you eat the most heinous
[ __ ] ever dog
like so taco bell is also up there with
mcdonald's in regards to you can just
point at the menu and be like give me
that
and you just know it's gonna be
definitely not true bruh
taco bell's like a box of chocolates
like
everything at taco bell's got the same
taste it's got that taco bell taste
you know what they got you brainwashed
you're married to the brands nah man
that's taco bell smacking boy listen
only thing i ever had to talk about that
was trash was like a couple weeks ago
or when when did i cheat on my diet
maybe like a month ago
dog keep it 100 that was last week we've
been on this keto for
about the same time you were on the
phone with me though when i was it i
think i ordered like a red uh
icy drink it was like a
starburst yeah you got two of them and i
said oh is the other one for your wifey
you said nah
they vote for me i'm gonna try i was i
just want to try them
and them shits were horrible i threw
them shits out
but that being said you get a chalupa
you get a quesadilla that [ __ ]
chicken quesadilla whatever special taco
bell sauce comes in that [ __ ]
[ __ ] fire you get a mexican pizza
[ __ ] fire
you get the goddamn doritos tacos locos
whatever the [ __ ]
[ __ ] fire supreme always go supreme
at taco bell
always goes always yeah it's a mistake
if you don't you get that bean and
cheese burrito
no onion run that [ __ ] up with all the
mild sauce
and i've been i've been learning some
tricks you go on the app you can
customize like the 99 cent menu
you get the goddamn fiesta cheese
potatoes in the little bowl
cheesy fiesta potatoes no you got that
99 cent menu
and then you you just subtract like the
cheese and the rice out of the cheesy
rice bean and cheese burrito and then
you got a straight up bean and cheese
burrito that usually costs two dollars
for a dollar
oh you're welcome so instead of you
ordering a bean and cheese burrito for
two dollars you say i want the
the dollar burrito but minus the rice
damn i never thought of that taco bell
with the quesadilla too
the low carbohydrates taco bell is all
fire
i really think in general you can go
down the list of
of of fast food restaurants and just be
like all this [ __ ] is fire
except burger king
i still [ __ ] with a whopper no i i there
are things that burger king i
thoroughly enjoy like a whopper but i do
think i don't have any confidence
if i were to go to burger king and just
point at the menu and be like yeah nah
hey wendy's got some [ __ ] heat
whataburger got heat wendy's got heat
whataburger is the other one where you
can just go up and down the menu
everything's fire
del taco's got some heat delta tacos
underrated
especially with the burgers people don't
know about the del taco taco and the
crinkle cup fries from del taco
bruh but burger king is trash bro
welcome back to keto talk hey burger
king is
[ __ ] trash there's no way you
you rank fast food spots
and burger kings anywhere else but last
place
though we're taking a whopper over a big
neck
oh yeah i actually agree hey you know
what else is trash but
but good that is right above burger king
in the trash list is jack in the box i
was gonna say
good old jack jack in the box is like
your abusive friend that
is just there whenever you need him like
man it's three in the morning nam
nothing's open but jack-in-the-box is
open oh yeah
our buddy jack's there run me those two
[ __ ] tacos for 99 cents you [ __ ] you
slide me that breakfast jack damn
anyway well that was nice uh wphx is a
uh
an esteemed mailman
he's a gambleholic
when's the last time you lost money at
the casino
i've been three days ago and they're
still open in arizona they just got
casinos just
[ __ ] covered yeah they got uh little
plastic dividers in between each machine
interesting it's like you're in the
little booth and they
check your they take a picture and check
your temperature
all right well we'll we'll be back at it
soon enough buddy
um you stay on that keto you fat [ __ ]
i don't know after this talk dog i'm
kind of craving i bet you are craving
that goddamn meat
ain't you you [ __ ] chance anyway
uh follow him at wphx
he's there's nothing special there just
so yeah nothing a lot of retweets
yeah yeah go on his instagram account
and just look at the seven photos of
49ers people and his daughter he has
hey hey let me ask you a question who
would you rather [ __ ]
george kittle or jimmy g
when you go through this [ __ ] again
who'd you rather [ __ ]
if you had to [ __ ] one of those guys
which one would it be
you go first oh i'm not i didn't i i i'm
not answering
are you not in this i'm not answering
the question either
[ __ ] you know it's jimmy g he's [ __ ]
gorgeous all right
what do you want me to say i got you to
admit you'd [ __ ] a man on the podcast
all right buddy enjoy your night all
right let me stop recording this
hold on